welcome to this video new part
of the middle game strategy series
yeah in this game we're going to look at
a
very
typical type of
sacrifice that happens time and time and
again
in various openings structures
you know it's hard to
put a certain tech to it like it always
happens there or
this opening
let's have a look at this sample game
that shows um the type of sacrifice that
i'm getting at
it's a game by
michael former world champion
at the time former world champion this
game is from 1970 and his opponent is
antanas kolarov a bulgarian player
who represented the bulgarian team in
this european team championships in 1970
so
don't really have any big information
about him but if bulgaria is usually
pretty decent at chess so
should have been a pretty good player
let's see what happened in this game we
have a karo khan
black play g6 yeah a setup that
is um even
popular would be a little bit too much
but it is played even today
this combination of c6d5 with the fear
and shadow
it's a pretty solid way for black to
play
tar played with knight f3 and h3
this to this day is the main line
the idea
behind this h3 move is that black wants
to get out his bishop and this is not so
easily possible here
no g through g4
no way but there are no no good other
squares
so black here has a choice he can take
on e4 he can play
knight f6 or knight h6 yeah those moves
are also possible this move
or for the creative player knight h6
black however played differently just
took on e4 which is the main line
probably or the
the simplest line white recaptures
97. now we have a pretty
karo khan type of pawn structure d and e
pawn are exchanged
and white has a good simple development
bishop c4
the best diagonal for the bishop
knight f6 and here white just trades
note that this is definitely more
promising
than retreating
very often you should consider to keep
pieces on the board if you have more
space
which here knight g3 does you keep more
pace no more pieces on the board
but here
note that the knight only looks at
squares
that are controlled by black so the
knight is not doing very much it's just
simpler
to trade on f6
simple and good
takes
castles yeah again h3
is a useful move bishop g4 is not
possible
yeah black castled
and the rookie one very logical move
putting the rook on this half open e
file maybe putting pressure on e7
black now went bishop f5
possible a possible move other moves on
knight d5 or something like that
knight e5 yeah very
typical play putting pressure on f7
combined pressure of knight and bishop
makes it a bit difficult for black to
arrange his pieces
yeah black now i think played a somewhat
questionable maneuver
he played bishop e4
this loses quite some time
especially if you consider that after
bishop g5 played by tar
now the bishop on e4 is indirectly
attacked as white threatens to take here
and then take on e4
so it has to move again bishop d5
this was probably black's concept he
wanted to
sort of with the snake-like maneuver
yeah he wanted to
try to neutralize this pressure on the
on the diagonal
so
of course tal is not obliging he's not
trading he keeps this important piece on
the board
and rather asks like okay you put your
bishop on d5 is this a stable square are
you sure
in fact it's difficult to keep this
this bishop there
black
went to e6
which is um preparing the next move what
he wants to do is he wants to get rid of
the e5 knight
but he cannot do it like that as this
is simply
losing the e7 pawn
so this bishop e6 move that he played is
preparing knight d7
tar played c3 of course d4
was hanging we need to
give some protection to that
black went 97 and of course we are not
trading but we retreat to f3 we keep
pieces on the board black has less space
and has problems to free himself
in addition this knight f3 move also
intends the following the following um
yeah typical exchange sacrifice i'm
going to spoil it a bit here
white is going to sacrifice only six
this is the
sacrifice that i'm talking about
and to be honest if you have some
experience
in in those kind of chess middle games
you not really see this as a sacrifice
in fact i'm going so far to say that
after rookie 8 that which
was played by black the move rook takes
c6 now played by tar
is almost an automatic move it really
for a good player
sorry this kind of move
should be the first that he considers
and it needs some serious
yeah
there need to be very serious reasons in
the position why not to sacrifice
the
the thing is that the the benefits
are very apparent quickly if we look at
this black of course has to take the
rook
and now white actually has a choice he
can he has two
very promising continuations one played
by tal the other also
quite um quite promising tal played
queen e2
instead there also was bishop c4
both moves
might even
transpose into one another
here white simply has a has a strong
position as well he's attacking this
pawn
and um yeah black has a hard time to
even keep it he can but only with a
passive move the main difference between
bishop c4 and queen e2 is that now the
pawn is also pinned it cannot advance
after queen e2 played in the game can
show this briefly queen e2
black went e5 returning a pawn it's not
a problem white is better after that
but this is the difference between
bishop c4 and the queen after bishop c4
black cannot return
what happens um the pawn if if if he
like if let's say black
defends passively after that knight f8 a
possible line
how do we continue
the thing is this is a purely strategic
secret sacrifice white is not in a hurry
to let's say i get a mating attack or or
do something drastic in the next couple
of moves white is just building up
based on the fact that simply
his minor pieces and especially this
fantastic bishop
is just this is better than a rook in
this position look at the e8 rook
yeah this is just a piece that's doing
nothing it's looking at its own pawn
and those two pawns this very important
point
they sort of split the board
they
are absolutely hindering black
from coordinating his forces in a useful
way
white
given time might even start a kingside
attack let's say a knight to e5
and then push the h pawn just one plan
so
this is a very very nice compensation
for white black has no way really to
make his his rooks felt in the near
future and we have many many weaknesses
that we can play
play for
yeah directly this pawn but notice we're
not taking the pawn
the pressure is much more much more
useful
let's say a5 to continue this this line
a4 takes takes
queen here bishop e3 this is a purely
strategic sacrifice that gives white
huge compensation in form of
this wrecked pawn structure black's
pieces are totally ineffective
we go back to the game
so this was bishop c4m
tar played queen e2
the choice between the two is pretty
much matter of taste both
both lead to very strong play
here
black
was able to return the pawn okay
so we give the check first
king h8
and d takes e5 so in this position we
have a one upon in addition
and we still have an excellent
compensation
we look at this queen c7 is definitely
the best move black needs to connect
rooks and put some pressure on e5
yeah white now can play bishop f7
rook f8 and e6
this is a very strong maneuver
it again
comparable to the situation mentioned
before when there were two e pawns for
black
those two pawns cut the board in half
white will gain very serious attacking
chances what he needs to do white
is to involve his queen in the attack
and we see that this happens quickly
black plays knight f6
knight e5 was also a possibility and may
be tougher
hard to tell white also has an excellent
position here something like this
yeah is also excellent for for white he
still has a great control the queen
influences
both wings and uh
yeah there's a king side a king attack
on the king brewing
and there are ideas like like this and
so on there are many many attacking
ideas
maybe still this was tougher it's it's
hard to tell black played um knight to
f6
and now we see a key maneuver which was
of course found by tali
it's
yeah at least one of maybe the the
greatest attacking player of all time
and
he knows what to do in this position
what white needs is the queen in the
attack so queen c4 strong
going here
and to h4
and there's that's exactly the spot
where the queen belongs near the king
queen a5
rook e1
yeah first rookie one
supporting the e file that's very
important
so
the thing is what black maybe wants to
do is to make a counter sacrifice here
and with the rook on e1 we look at these
seven pawns so if black does this
counter sacrifice
we immediately look at this weak pawn
and are very much ready to take it
so a good
prep move
yeah what did black do he played queen
d5
and white went to h4 yeah here we come
to a funny situation white now has
numerous threats
bishop takes g6
is one thread and knight d5 is the other
main threat intending knight g6
yeah it's it is really the case black is
helpless and all pieces are
getting transferred near the king and
this attack is simply
yeah cannot survive this
and this is especially problematic
keeping away or taking away many a pawn
squares for black king
yeah black now played rook takes d7 and
now
tar found a nice way to finish this off
he played knight to e5
that's really funny
yeah white
threatening knight g6 and knight f7 if
black now
secures the rook
he will with this check
lose the queen instead
so that's even worse
yeah so black black played rook f8
didn't play rook f8 sorry
he played after 95 he played knight h5
yeah so just allowing this well it's not
great you know but
the alternative
so white now is say it's just two pawns
up and still has a fantastic attack
yeah black played rookie 8
bishop f6 yeah black is just about
holding on
around here there are various ways to
win tal is going for one that is pretty
reliable
here we see a position where white has
this strong pin still going
he has a pawn an extra pawn on the king
side and he has got the baton and he's
got the better minor piece
queen b3
yeah here black
played king evade yeah that's not
exactly the toughest defense
but um
it seems that from a technical point of
view queen d5 is the toughest but after
that white can just trade
and get to a winning endgame however
this is the continuation that would have
prolonged the game
yeah quite considerably yeah black
played king f8 but this is now very easy
rook t1 queen move and now bishop h6
yeah this is deadly now there's rook d8
in the mix queen b7 in the mix
after rook d6
rook d6 black resigned after just queen
takes here and queen b7
white is
winning with this
strong threat against g7 he will trade
off all pieces and then win with two
extra pawns in the king and pawn
end game
yeah
what is the the lesson to be learned
from this game
in this type of structure if we go all
the way back
here
it is a very very common idea to
sacrifice the exchange
this kind of situation
this of course
as mentioned
is not specific to this particular
opening
there are many openings and then
possible
setups where this can happen
the characteristics is that very often
not all the time but very often it is a
bishop that is taken
to weaken the color complex of the
bishop that is that is taken like here
the light squares we saw that the light
squares were key especially this strong
diagonal
where a piece
is coming
or this later the queen to see for all
on the light squares
and
another characteristic is that
this this pawn is double pawn it hinders
the coordination of
of
the defending side
just to show that it happens
from all kinds of openings i can
show you a totally totally different
opening where the exchange sacrifice
might happen just a moment
yeah back to the starting position i can
put up
something that
if you follow my blitz games you know
well i do the play the bogo indian often
due to my
my book project and here this is the the
line that i have
i have chosen as black
and
here in this in this opening you
sometimes get um
and get something like that
just putting up
some some possible moves
this was actually imprecise
something like that let's say
um b3 it's not it's not a forced thing
here i just want to show the
the general idea
and here
here in this kind of structure it is
very very interesting for black
to sacrifice the exchange
yeah and this is quite comparable to the
situation in the tower game of course
here it is not
as favorable as black is not having this
kind of space advantage that um
that um in the tar game was was adding
to his uh to his um
to his assets but still this is a very
interesting way to play
with
the queen may be putting pressure here
knight g4 coming the dark squares are
very much weakened
this especially gains in strength if the
h pawn is moved i recently had a blitz
game where h3 was even played and then
the complex here of weak squares were
this was enormous
so
this can happen in all kinds of
positions and really should be
considered very often the position is
rather close so the rooks cannot do that
much and you have good play on those
weakened squares
of course there should be some sort of
support of this um
this considerations with with concrete
lines it's good to check if you can keep
those structural advantages of there
some way to
to um
for for the defending side to get out of
it but very important is to sometimes
just give it a try try to play this
and see how you handle the situation
with the uneven material
yeah i hope you enjoyed this it's a very
important motif that happens quite often
if you have the chance go for it thanks
for watching